there are numerous words of Yiddish
origin in English probably because
Yiddish is so expressive but probably
also because of the large Jewish
population in New York City a culturally
influential City a few examples glitch
which means malfunction it comes from
the Yiddish word glitch meaning a slip
shtick which means a gimmick or
performance routine often a comedic one
it comes from schtick meaning an act or
a gimmick but the literal meaning is a
piece or a slice Klutz which means a
clumsy person it comes from clots
literally a block or a lump shmuck which
means a person Unworthy of respect
whether a jerk or a fool it comes from
schmuck which in Yiddish actually refers
to a man's
speaking of a man's
there's the English word schlong which
comes from Yiddish shlang which actually
means snake you can see the connection
Spiel which is like a pitch or someone
trying to sell you on something it comes
from Yiddish Spiel meaning play or game
or the German word Spiel with the same
meaning